here's the headline
giant kites could pull cargo ships
across the ocean and slash their carbon
emissions you may have seen kite Surfers
in action harnessing the power of the
wind to pull them over the sea now
imagine try to imagine this the same
concept applied to a one thousand square
meter kite flying 300 meters above the
water only instead of towing a surfer
across the waves it's helping to propel
a colossal cargo ship across the ocean
well that's the basic idea behind the
c-wing a technology being developed is
being developed now this is obviously in
the very early stages being developed by
French company air Seas which it says
could help cargo ships reduce their fuel
consumption and cut their carbon
emissions by an average of 20 percent
the Liberals have just discovered the
concept of sailboats
sailboats were invented in 4000 BC
at least